[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle saison et ce premier
numéro du 7 8 sociétés pour cette
rentrée nous allons parler éducation et
plus principalement de la méthode
montessori ces écoles pratiquement ce
système ne cesse d'augmenter il y en a
environ 200 dans l'hexagone pour en
parler avec moi ce soir
manuela à fond choquant c'est le
président de l'apec à montigny le
bretonneux genre à la pep c'est alors la
pub c'est là l'association vers la
fédération de parents d'élèves de
l'enseignement public association qui a
pour but de de porter des valeurs
fondamentales telles que le parent est
le premier éducateur de son enfant et
surtout d'assister par le biais
d'associations locales
les équipes pédagogiques dans leur
mission d'éducation des enfants en face
de vous diane d'orléans bonsoir vous
êtes directrice de l'école montessori el
nido à orgeval
depuis trois ans c'est ça donc j'y vais
une fois ci je me suis déplacé ensuite
sur cheval djamel ami cofondateur de
l'école main dans la main première école
montessori attrape c'est bien ça pour
soi ouvert les portes justement c'est
pas salé ouvrir exactement le 2
septembre avec l'aide de tout le monde
on a pu ouvrir les portes à le 2
septembre mais en a eu un reportage un
de vos confrères et on est content et
enfin et xavier henry
bonsoir vous êtes éducateurs de l'école
montessori des orchidées à port marly
vous avez travaillé dans d'autres
endroits notamment la suisse ont veillé
bon soir je vais éducateurs montessori
j'ai travaillé trois ans en maternelle
après m'être formés et avoir obtenu le
diplôme de l'association montessori
internationale pour le maternel est
depuis quatre ans pour la l'école
élémentaire maintenant à port marly à
l'école les orchidées
merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour ceux qui nous regardent
et qui ne connaissent pas la méthode
montessori c'est au départ maria
montessori une pédiatre italienne qui a
inventé une méthode pédagogique
la méthode montessori centré autour de
l'autonomie de l'enfant et du rythme de
chacun elle a travaillé notamment dans
des quartiers pauvres de rome et auprès
d'enfants audi handicapées en milieu
hospitalier aujourd'hui les écoles
montessori accueille tous les enfants
diane d'orgeval dont vous êtes
directrice d'une école montessori
comment ça se passe une journée dans une
école montessori
alors on a un temps de travail qui se
décompose deux heures le matin et deux
l'après midi où il ya vraiment une
manipulation guider je dirais avec le
regard bienveillant de l'éducateur qui
va après observer son enfant lui permet
d'aller se diriger vers certains
ateliers
on s'y tient temps de repas alors c'est
un peu comme une maison donc on met la
table en débarrasse on prend soin non
seulement de soi mais de l'ambiance et
des ses camarades et ensuite on repart
au travail après une petite récréation
jusqu'à la fin la journée on retrouve
ses parents avec la méthode montessori
on parle plus d'éducateurs que
d'enseignants même si la formation est
d'environ 800 heures avant de prendre
une classe en main et xavier henry vous
êtes éducateurs et bénéficier de neuf
ans d'expérience quels sont les thèmes
et des ateliers destinés aux enfants
dans votre classe alors en élémentaire
on dit que les enfants sont curieux de
tout et qu'il faudrait pouvoir leur
apporter tout l'univers donc par contre
on peut pas connaître tout sur l'univers
mais en fait comme l'enfant est centrale
en montessori on l'être surtout
apprendre par lui-même à faire par
lui-même et à faire des recherches et à
apprendre dans les secteurs qu'ils
s'intéressent le plus mais après on
l'amène aussi dans la transversalité
vers d'autres domaines donc tous les
domaines peuvent être peuvent être
abordés même la climatologie ou
l'histoire de la musique c'est aussi
vaste que la connaissance peut l'être
j'avais à la mli je me tourne vers vous
avez
décidé de créer votre école montessori à
l'aide d'autres parents c'est justement
quand même le plus dans la méthode
moment théorie c'est que en fait on
adule enfants allaient à son rythme en
fait celui qui veut aller à trois
kilomètres à l'heure enfin pirates qui
aiment à travers et celui qui va à des
kilomètres heure ni rsa il ira dans ce
sens aussi on a créé l'école justement
pour essayer de trouver un cadre
montessori à 100% parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de l'organisme aujourd'hui
qu'ils prétendent être montessori et
justement en fait il ya des méthodes
respecté pour avoir ce normand théorie
maria montessori l'a choisie ne pas
déposer justement le moment théorique du
coup il ya beaucoup d éditeurs et
fabricants de jouets aussi qu'ils
prétendent a commenté survie justement
nous on fait avec cette initiative avec
les parents on a dit on va essayer de
faire un projet sur lequel on va
respecter le maximum possible en fait la
méthode montessori
en tant que présidente de l'ape est
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
pédagogie montessori
alors en tant que présidente de l'ape et
je ne suis pas vraiment sûre d'avoir à à
penser quoi que ce soit de particulier
de cette méthode car c'est une méthode
d'enseignement qui en vaut une autre en
soyons bien d'accord elle a fait ses
preuves et est bon voilà après moi ce
soir j'aimerais me positionner plus en
tant que maman en tant que
en tant que personne qui éduque un
enfant et qui a à coeur son éducation
également la méthode montessori a des
avantages certains
elle permet elle permet l'autonomie de
l'enfant elle lui permet d'apprendre et
d'apprendre par d'autres manières que
par son cerveau il apprend par le
toucher il apprend par le son il apprend
à développer sa curiosité et c'est
quelque chose de merveilleux
après on a quand même été formé dans une
société où des fondamentaux sont
attendus et ses fondamentaux
il faut un jeu je ne sais pas trop
comment ils sont atteints par le biais
des éducateurs chacun connaît son
travail je pense que vous le faites très
bien mais l'école aujourd'hui nécessite
des apprentissages ferme
elle s'ouvre à de nouvelles méthodes
d'enseignement parce que la société
évolue et qu'il faut évoluer avec elle
et que les méthodes d'enseignement
commence à devenir désuète et il y a une
réelle conscience de ça mais est ce que
la méthode a elle-même suffit je n'ai
pas les données pour répondre à cette
question
alors justement avec la méthode
montessori l'enfant par exemple fait les
activités autant de fois qu'il le veut
est ce que on peut pas parler un peu de
l'enfant roi ça c'est la phrase atypique
que dès qu'on parle de montessori où on
parle de l'enfant roi je suis pas
d'accord parce qu'en fait l'enseignant
il est là pour justement un résultat
aussi les enseignants face justement la
concentration dans la méthode montessori
c'est super important
l'enseignant fallait l'enseignant
montessori s'il doit voir l'enfant faire
le même exercice 30 femmes et le lanceur
transforme alors justement quels sont
les bénéfices qu'en tant que directrice
ou enseignants parce qu'elle peut
revenir sur l'enfant moi oui en fait
l'enfant roi c'est ce qui alors à tout
faire en fait ont été sauvés c'est
complètement l'opposé on va permettre à
l'enfant de manipuler un atelier mais à
partir du moment où leur présenter fait
avec une première fois après à ce moment
là pour répéter autant de fois qu'il
veut parce que c'est confiance en soi en
fait qui s'installe en ces vidéos
le de jean la confiance on apprend
beaucoup par la répétition il suffit de
voir les programmes de l'éducation
nationale moi j'ai été prof d'anglais au
collège
le programme est le même en 6e et en 5e
en quatrième mais aussi beaucoup de
répétitions à l'école nationale
seulement c'est toujours verticale
l'enseignement en fait tant que tant qu
on s'intéressera à chercher des méthodes
d'enseignement les écoles montessori en
grand en poupe
pourquoi nous ne sommes pas des
enseignants parce qu'enseigner en fait
c'est faire un cours académiques à un
groupe
nous ne dirais pas un groupe nous gérons
l'individu est en fait on étudie dans
l'information les modes de développement
l'un comment l'enfant se développe
comment l'enfant apprend et comment
l'aider à apprendre on n'est pas là pour
lui donner le savoir en espérant déjà
qu'ils nous entendent qu'ils nous
écoutent qui comprennent et qui mémorise
on est là pour lui donner tous les
moyens de comprendre par lui-même et
c'est le meilleur moyen pour lui
d'acquérir la connaissance mais pas
seulement d'acquérir de la connaissance
comme pourrait faire un médecin en sept
ans à cette année d'études c'est aussi
apporter la transversalité qui développe
l'intelligence et pas seulement la
connaissance et en allant au rythme de
l'enfant est ce que il n'ya pas un
décalage qui se crée avec le programme
justement de l'éducation nationale je
dirais qu'en fait quand on permet à
l'enfant d'aller à son rythme il va
aller vers ses centres d'intérêt et du
coup aller beaucoup plus vite qu'un
enfant est auquel on dirait annoncé
maintenant on fait des maths donc tu
viens et c'est ton moment alors qu'il
intéressait part je ne suis pas
l'apprentissage de la lecture on va
carrément c'est à côté
vous l'avez remarqué également enfin
l'intérêt enfin je même mensonge un
deuxième enfant aussi et qui encore un
peu jeune mais je compte bien le mettre
à la méthode montessori parce que je
trouve ça génial en fait de pousser
l'enfant dans le sens où il a envie
aller et conservant sa beaucoup plus
vite que ce qu'on pense justement c'est
le même accompagner parce qu'on n'est
pas là pour les pousser en fait c'est on
leur permet de développer ce qu'ils ont
en eux en fait c'est ça qui est
important en fait c'est non c'est non
classe au doigt la cote
l'enfant est l'enfant n'a pas de notes
il n'y a pas d'évaluation dans les
écoles flamandes et karianne en fait
qu'on fait c'est qu'on essaye d'amener
l'enfant à l'autocorrection parce que
l'autocar corruption mais pas quelque
chose de punitif en fait qui peut mettre
à mal à l'accord la confiance en soi
au contraire lorsqu'on voit une erreur
ce que l'on fait c'est quoi on la note
pour nous de façon à revenir vers des
présentations qui vont lui permettre de
corriger ses erreurs et quelques
semaines quelques mois après on lui
soumet son travail pour qu'il puisse
voir un mais là j'ai fait une erreur et
qu'ils puissent voir ses progrès là à la
base en fait montessori elle a fait une
découverte et l a dit s'ils n'avaient
pas découvert ça je n'aurais rien
découvert elle a découvert que les
enfants de maternelle avait besoin
d'avoir les pieds au sol pour se
concentrer donc à la nuit tous les
meubles à la taille des enfants
les lits par terre voilà les les lits
par terre pour les enfants les plus
jeunes même avant l'école et des chaises
qui peut leur permettre d'avoir les
pieds au sol et en fait il ya trois
critères pour que l'enfant puisse
accéder à la concentration en maternelle
c'est pieds au sol c'est manipulation
d'un matériel intelligent avec un but
intelligent et le troisième c'est que
l'enfant ait choisi l'activité
donc ça c'est la grande difficulté
surtout quand on accepte des enfants qui
n'ont pas fait la maternelle montessori
parce qu'en fait avec une éducation
verticale les enfants n'ont pas de choix
à faire on leur donne de quoi de quoi
apprendre dans montessori c'est
complètement différent et simplement
c'est une façon de leur permettent de se
concentrer dès le plus jeune âge c'est
tout cette pédagogie montessori sans
notation
vous approuvez vous n'approuvez pas
alors je tiens encore une fête de nouvel
exercice est temps que je n'ai pas à
approuver ou désapprouver quoi que ce
soit je suis en tant que je suis là en
tant que parent la notation en soi c'est
déjà un sujet qui est en cours de
discussion dans les services de
l'éducation nationale on s'est bien
rendu compte que la pédagogie n'était
pas totalement pour constructive avec la
notation les méthodes de notation ont
évolué maintenant on est plus dans de
l'encouragement plutôt que dans tout
simplement montré les faiblesses et les
torts de chaque élève
là où la méthode montessori prend tout
son sens dans l'école c'est dans ce fait
de faire gagner de l'autonomie à
l'enfant et monsieur blanc caire
lui-même a reconnu lors de différentes
interviews qu'il y a vraiment beaucoup à
apprendre de la méthode montessori pour
l'éducation nationale actuelle est
d'ailleurs beaucoup de professeurs se
forment sur leur temps personnel parce
qu'il faut bien savoir que ce genre de
formations ne sont pas prises en charge
par l'éducation nationale
il se forme sur leur temps personnel et
n'hésite pas à mettre en place certaines
méthodes directement dans les classes de
dans les classes
aujourd'hui la première des méthodes qui
est mise en place c'est d'ailleurs de
laisser à l'enfant la liberté d'aller
rejoindre un autre niveau pour faire une
activité qui lui convient après l
avantage de cette méthode c'est qu'elle
est toujours dans la bienveillance et
c'est ce qu'on recherche
de nos jours vraiment à évoluer dans la
bienveillance une réaction oui je dirais
alors de la bienveillance je pense que
si un enfant n'a pas confiance il peut
pas se mettre dans le travail sent pas
en sécurité et lettres aux aguets va pas
pouvoir se vraiment se fixer ses
objectifs après une autre chose par
rapport aux notes en fait en août et
sourit il ya peut-être pas de notes mais
par contre on a une idée précise des
compétences qui sont acquises par
l'enfant moi je sais dans mon école je
pense aussi dans toutes les écoles
d'ailleurs on a un livret avec ma
présence
il en est à tel endroit au niveau de la
lecture ou tel endroit et ses listes et
de manière très précise de avec trois
critères enfin en tout cas pour mon
école c'est en qu'elle est en cours
d'acquisition ati non acquis et voilà
les fidjiens pour tu vois là vous voyez
aller pour le système le système et des
vérifications éducation nationale
également imaginé avec les évaluations
syfy citer aussi c'est qu'on ne fixe pas
d'objectif à l'enfant parce que
généralement lorsqu au fixe un objectif
à un enfant ici arrête alors qu'en fait
si on nous en fixent pas il peut le
dépasser très largement
on suit le programme de l'éducation
nationale parce que on se doit de le
faire on veut pas que nos l'émeut les
familles soient condamnés à laisser
leurs enfants jusqu'à la fin lorsque
l'arrêté dans nos écoles mais qu'ils
aient la possibilité s'ils le souhaitent
d'aller dans le public à n'importe quel
moment de scolarité même s'il est
préférable terminé un cycle où une
moitié de cycle en tout cas on ne fixe
pas d'objectif mais ils sont largement
dépassées dans la plupart des cas c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'en formation
élémentaire on apprend à calculer la
tubik sur feuilles même les
mathématiciens ne le font pas ils le
font avec des machines pourquoi nous on
le fait sur feuilles c'est pour pouvoir
apporter de la nourriture à des esprits
qui veulent les mathématiques et qui
sont lassés d'être d'exercice qui ne
leur correspondent plus on peut aller
très très loin et les écoles montessori
concerne la maternelle et la primaire
pourquoi ne pas continuer jusqu'au
collège le ca périgueux lassé par les
équipes au lycée alors je vous propose
d'écouter justement à la vie de parent
yvelinois le fait de laisser libre les
enfants et je trouve ça vraiment une
bonne initiative
j'ai beaucoup déçu dessus qui en parler
positivement
mais malheureusement le prix école et
qu'on n'est pas tous accès et du coup je
pense pas à m petit plus tard là dedans
ils sont libres de d'aller et venir
comme ils veulent
et tandis que dans les écoles classiques
ou en accompagnant c'est qu'ils sont
toujours obligés de rester assis de
répondre à certaines règles assez
strictes par la notation par le manque
de notation dans une méthode montessori
je pense que justement ça laisse aller
ça implique mans et cette compétition et
cette concurrence le premier le deuxième
de la classe et ses 5000 euros par part
en c'est un gros frein effectivement
c'est un frein
c'est un frein pour je pense la majorité
des familles alors on l'a entendu ça
vous a fait un peut débattre le prix les
écoles montessori sont hors contrat donc
la scolarité a un coût 6000 euros par an
pour votre école
main dans la main 6710 euros par an pour
la maternelle dans l'école el nido plus
et 400 euros de frais d'inscription en
primaire c'est 7550 euros par an + 400
euros de frais d'inscription et vous
propose également des repas bio pour un
près de 1400 euros aux parents pour
l'école des orchidées où vous exercez
l'année s'élève à 7500 euros + 350 euros
de frais d'inscription vous propose
également des forfaits repas en plus
c'est une offre éducative qu'on pourrait
penser réservé à l'élite
c'est vrai c'est le problème de
montessori c'est vrai que ça reste très
élitiste même si au départ
maria montessori était à san remo à rome
avec des enfants dans un quartier
défavorisé
aujourd'hui quand même comme ça marche
très bien en fait est que ça coûte très
cher pourquoi ça coûte très cher c'est
très simple le budget d'une école déjà
la moitié du budget c'est le foncier
c'est à dire que pour avoir ses locaux
ça lui coûte la moitié de son budget
après il ya beaucoup de matériel moi je
viens d'ouvrir une classe par exemple on
a eu plus de 20000 euros
d'investissement de matériel donc ça
c'est encore un tiers du budget il ya un
deuxième tiers ça fait même plus que 1,1
entier on sent des faux la saison s'est
laissé les salaires donc c'est pour ça
que ça coûte aussi cher
si un jour ça pouvait être subventionné
par par l'éducation nationale nationale
rtnc qu'elles sont passées sans faire
une visite ou l'école montessori et
publics notamment en 1946 elle est allée
aux états unis certains états des états
unis sont montessori le cac40 montessori
et maintenant ça doit te 15% de monter
ce rien pourquoi parce que ça développe
beaucoup la créativité notamment les
deux fondateurs de google sont des
enfants remonter ce rien amazon ou
wikipedia aussi je crois enfin voilà
celle ça développe la confiance en soi
à partir du moment où l'on développe la
confiance en soi d'un enfant on a pu à
s'intéresser à un programme parce qu'il
va le dépasser très largement
quand on a confiance en soi en avant et
vite quand on dit qu'on respecte le
rythme de l'enfant
oui c'est vrai mais à partir du moment
où il a confiance en lui je peux vous
dire que son rythme il est largement
bonne vitesse de croisière qui me paraît
important c'est que l'échec en cela le
fait d'avoir fait une erreur c'est
génial en fait l'enfant se disent
choqués que c'est ce que je fais
travailler
donc c'est pas du tout la même
perception ne m'en vante le vrai
matériel montessori s'auto corriger
l'enfant il va faire le cycle il va en
devenir et bassecourt et j'ai lui même
il doit se rendre compte pas c'est ici
qu'il avait justement une erreur et
c'est à partir de là il va avancer
ça c'est maria montessori qui nous
amenait à macquarie l'auto correctifs et
on n'a pas besoin d'intervenir et la
différence entre une école manque les
ori une école dite normale au niveau des
salaires des enseignants plus et c'est
pareil c'est la paix maintenant on a une
vie tarifaire qu'à peu près pareil
peut-être qu'en fin de carrière ils sont
mieux payés parce qu'on n'a pas les
moyens à lire je ne sais pas je ne
pourrais pas travailler dans l'éducation
nationale et j'ai toujours travaillé en
montessori
je commence à bien gagner ma vie parce
que j'ai 10 ans d'expérience j'ai connu
céline alvarez avec qui j'étais en
formation maternelle qui donc elle vient
du l'éducation nationale malheureusement
lorsqu'il ya eu changement de
gouvernement
tous les robinets ont été fermés et son
projet alors qu'elle devait former
normalement ouvrir 40 maternelle
montessori pour l'éducation nationale
bîmes envoyé à la poubelle donc je ne
sais pas est un autre point qui vous a
fait réagir dans les témoignages que
nous avons entendu une maman qui
disaient ils viennent ils s'en vont ça
vous a fait réagir dans la classe elle
voulait sûrement dire qu'il y avait pas
obligation de s'asseoir toute la journée
certains enfants donc les casses
montessori a le choix de s'installer par
terre sur un tapis ou assis sur une
chaise ou rester debout à observer les
autres parce qu'on apprend beaucoup en
observant on aura une liberté de
déplacement ne peuvent pas quand on n'a
pas besoin de faire ce qu'il a envie de
faire complètement un objectif et un
sujet qui est très délicat à montessori
on y passe beaucoup de temps en
formation c'est dit
liberté et discipline discipliné liberté
en fait la liberté les possibles dans un
cadre clairement défini un cadre strict
on peut pas dire que montessori n'a pas
de règle en fait on a une multitude des
mines des règles de bienveillance et des
règles de courtoisie des règles de
fonctionnement de respect etc de
fonctionnement en équipe
moi j'ai j'ai travaillé pendant trois
ans dans l'école d'application du centre
de formation nantais story france quand
j'étais en maternelle mi juin on a eu la
visite d'un préfet et d'un éducateur de
l'inspecteur d'académie de l'éducation
nationale qui sont arrivés en
costume-cravate etc je leur ai donné et
d'une directrice est à dire vous asseyez
à l'a1 là vous observez vous ne parlez
pas et on fait un débrief en fin de
matinée ils étaient assez là la bouche
pincée au début et en fait on a vu leur
bouche s'ouvrir et à en perdre haleine
c'était impressionnant on en abuse des
briefings et ils m'ont dit mais on a vu
des enfants de maternelle faire des
divisé dénombre avec des centaines de
millions oui oui d'autres qui révisait
l'étape de soustraction ou
multiplication j'en ai vu un qui faisait
de l'analyse complexe de la phrase oui
oui avec le la nature des mots etc il
dit nous dans l'éducation nationale mi
juin
ça fait déjà deux semaines pour la
sortie les jeux de société parce qu'on
n'arrive plus à les tenir
comment vous faites en fait nous ont
réussi à part en partant de l'enfant à
le mener là où il doit aller et c'est
parce que c'est justement pas verticale
qu'en fait on n'a pas besoin de sortir
les jeunes juin et ce sont souvent des
écoles bilingue anglais français donc il
ya vraiment une importance dans pour
l'enfant d'apprendre dès son plus jeune
âge une langue étrangère vous l'avez
constaté exactement fait non quand on
est devant l'école justement pour
récupérer les enfants ce qui est bien
c'est qu'on entend au moins cinq ou six
ans donc déjà de la part des parents
sans fin les enfants ou les écoute aussi
et c'est bien bilingue ya un minimum
anglais je pense à certaines qui font
espagnol aussi mais je veux dire très
peu mais c'est très sympathique ce
qu'ils le sont touchées augmente et
souris c'est super important alors des
failles font dessinent justement le plus
important pour les pour les langues
c'est l'oreille l'oreille elle est
absolue pour chaque nouveau né est en
fait elle va se concentrer sur la langue
maternelle et perdent en fait cette
capacité de pouvoir comprendre des
autres langues
assez vite en fait on dit qu'on doit
soumettre les enfants avant l'âge de 6
mois 1 mu à une multitude de langues
pour que cette oreille reste ouverte est
en fait plus ils pratiqueront jeunes
plus ils pourront apprendre à apprendre
facilement plus tôt on dit plus
l'environnement est riche et plus
l'enfant il ya il absorbe exactement vue
de 2 0 à 3 ans l'enfant absorbe de façon
inconsciente et niang absorber jusqu'à
six ans de façon plus consciente mais ce
sont des éponges
moi j'ai obtenu des enfants de
maternelle qui parlait jusqu'à cinq
langues en suisse les derniers points
est-ce que c'est facile de réintégrer le
circuit dit classique pour un enfant qui
était avant dans une école montessori ça
c'est la question en fin de vie les gens
qui me disent c'est nicole ça fait sept
ans qu'on a on a ouvert maintenant
et j'avoue qu'on a des enfants qui sont
passés dans le public dans le privé donc
je les suis un petit peu pour voir
comment on a en a fait 1100 mhz à
travailler correctement ou peur qu'en
fait et moi ce que j'ai vu c'est que les
enfants avaient une grande capacité à
s'adapter
je dis pas qu'ils sont heureux parce que
leur système est quand même très
différentes qui sont moins de liberté
mais la transmission il veut ça va ça va
attirer en ensemble le fait qu'ils aient
en plus la possibilité comme on disait
tout à l'heure de se lever et c
il ya beaucoup plus des changements
beaucoup plus d'enrichissement de
l'intelligence interpersonnelles de
l'intelligence sociale il ya huit
intelligence ça s'appelle les
intelligences multiples vous impliquez
vous invite à vous renseigner sur
parents si si si ça vous intéresse
8 intelligences multiples deux sont
développées dans l'éducation nationale
l'intelligence langagière l'intelligence
logico mathématique il existe
l'intelligence intra personnel inter
personnelles kinesthésique musicale
naturaliste et une dernière j'arrive
jamais de rappeler des vite en même
temps mais en tout cas non dans nos
écoles on essaye de tout les développer
parce que le but est de développer
uniformément et l'ailé
les les études montre l'expérience
notamment aux états unis pendant les
pays comme le japon les états unis
l'inde voulait aller les pays baltiques
les enfants qui sortent de montessori et
qui vont par exemple l'entrée en sixième
80% seront délégués de classe justement
pour ces raisons là parce qu'ils ne
savent pas juste compter et parler ils
ont développé une multitude
d'intelligence justement l'environnement
joue beaucoup si le rapport il faut pas
faire des statistiques par rapport à
chaque grille parce que j'abandonne
justement ce que j'ai vu ses
statistiques concernant le japon c'est
assez les japonais déjà ils sont assez
strictes et à dire enfin de l'éducation
d'un contre rapport à la culture
oui exactement à partir du moment
l'adaptabilité et à quel point c'est
important de développer l'adaptabilité
nous déjà on a dû s'adapter à internet
et aux smartphones etc
dans la génération sauront s'adapter
peut-être à des bouleversements
climatiques il ya plein d'autres choses
une multitude de choses c'est
l'adaptabilité qu'il faut développer en
priorité chez nos enfants
j'ai entendu parler en fait des
enseignants de l'éducation nationale qui
ils disent qu'ils ont du mal avec les
enfants qui viennent justement des
écoles montessori parce qu'il ya cette
il y aura deux toulousains toujours oui
et non en fait le plus difficile pour un
enfant venant de l'école montessori
c'est de prendre l'attitude d'élèves qui
est attendu par l'éducation nationale
c'est à dire de rester à sa chaise
pendant quelques quelques instants de ce
concentré de ne pas discuter avec ses
camarades pendant un exercice
vraiment cette histoire de discipline
attendu dans une salle de classe
alors attention je mets vraiment des
bémols
cette discipline est en cours de refonte
également à venise et voilà les
nouvelles générations de professeurs ont
bien conscience que les et les enfants
ont besoin de liberté même dans le cadre
de la classe la difficulté c'est de
faire comprendre un enfant qu'il va
passer d'une méthode d'enseignement une
autre
le tout dans une transition
de transition relativement court parce
que quand on quitte une école montessori
ou une autre méthode d'éducation pour
venir dans une classe normale
ben on a juste le temps des vacances
scolaires on a eu de moi à merde on
faisait paraître un sign on les prépare
en fait oui alors dit les choses qui
vont être différentes si on les prépare
bien un an avant une bonne solution
c'est le mind mapping les fiches ristic
qui permet aux enfants d'apprendre par
eux mêmes ils peuvent être au fond de la
classe et continue d'apprendre ce qu'ils
veulent merci à tous les cas d'avoir
participé la ccq société c'est la fin de
ce sept huit sociétés rendez vous
mercredi prochain ce bonne soirée
[Musique]